C'C'est une histoire qui
nene laisse personne indifféren,
cecelle d'une jeune femme
ququi avait besoin d'aide
etet qui ne l'a pas reçue.
JeJe pense qu'il faut que je
prprenne le temps pour le résumr
paparce que c'est une situation
drdramatique et complexe. C'est
l'l'histoire d'une jeune femme i
avavait besoin d'aide mais qui e
l'l'a pas reçu. Vous la voyez i,
AmAmélie Champagne, 22 ans. Elle
sosouffrait d'une profonde
dédétresse, une grande anxiété.
PePendant de longues années l'oa
chcherché la cause des maux qu'l
ininfligeait. On a émis toutes
sosortes d'hypothèses et
fifinalement il y a des médecins
ququi ont trouvé en juin que
c'c'était la maladie de Lyme.
CeCette maladie qui se traite et
AmAmélie souffrait toujours
d'd'anxiété et d'un mal profond.
UnUne situation qui s'est vraimt
dédégradée au point où elle a
mamanifesté d'exprimer des penss
susuicidaires à son frère. Elle
vovoulait qu'il lui fasse un nod
cocoulant. Elle a été amenée à
l'l'hôpital Douglas. Un psychiae
lala vue 25 minutes lui a presct
dedes pilules pour dormir. On ne
sasait pas ce qui s'est dit ente
lala patiente et le psychiatre
paparce que même les parents ne
sosont pas là à ce moment-là. On
nene sait pas ce qui s'est dit.
DoDonc on ne peut rien concluree
cecela. Mais Amélie va faire une
auautre tentative, une vraie
tetentative de suicide dans un c
enen Estrie et cette tentative a
l'l'amener à l'urgence de
l'l'hôpital de Sherbrooke. Ellea
papasser trois jours et deux nus
susur une civière dans des
coconditions affreuses, atroce.
PePersonne de sain d'esprit ne
vovoudrait passer ce temps sur e
cicivière à côté de Jean qui sot
enen crise alors qu'elle manquee
sosommeil. Amélie ne pouvait pas
êêtre prise en charge sur place,
c'c'est-à-dire l'hôpital.
PoPourquoi? On a évoqué la
prpratique habituelle et ses ce,
onon va se poser la question là-
dedessus. Elle avait le mauvais
cocode postal parce que son
adadresse était à Montréal et
l'l'hôpital de Sherbrooke, avec
unune urgence débordée et sans
dodoute pas de lit, a dit : on e
pepeut pas vous prendre, ce n'et
papas le bon code postal, allez-
vovous-en à Montréal. Mais pour
êêtre transféré à Montréal, ça e
sese fait pas en claquant des
dodoigts. Elle a voulu sortir de
l'l'urgence tellement c'était
inintolérable. Elle est rentrée
chchez ses parents qui l'ont
enentouré d'amour et de tous les
sosoins, de tous les camions et
leles beaux mots d'amour. Elle
dedevait rentrer à Notre-Dame à
MoMontréal le lundi i matin.
L'L'irréparable s'est produit.
ElElle a donc, elle sait enlever
lala vie le 11 septembre à
MoMontréal. Voici ce que son pèe
a a dit au micro de Paul Arcand.
ALALAIN CHAMPAGNE, père d'Amélie
- - C'est complètement
ininacceptable de cogner
àà des portes, de défoncer
dedes portes comme on l'a fait,
pupuis de se faire rejeter comme
çaça, là. Puis, de se faire dire
quque ma fille n'est pas en danr
imimmédiat pour elle-même alors
ququ'elle vient de tenter
dede se noyer deux jours avant,
ququ'elle n'a pas dormi,
onon me la retourne dans un pire
ététat qu'avant... puis, qu'elle
cocommette l'irréparable juste
ququelques heures après, c'est
ququoi la définition d'immédiat?
JeJe veux dire... C'est une heu,
dedeux heures, cinq heures,
didix heures? C'est quoi?
JeJe veux dire... Pour moi,
c'c'est une situation qui est...
d'd'avoir vécu les funérailles
dede ma fille en fin de semaine,
c'c'est un événement qui n'aurat
jajamais dû arriver.
M Mon message aux décideurs,
c'c'est : prenez action. C'est..
ilil y a eu deux belles
opopportrtunités, au Douglas,
àà Sherbrooke de prendre une
papatiente en charge, qui parle
ououvertement de se suicider
ouou qui vient de faire une
tetentative, puis on ne le fait
papas. T'as beau défoncer
dedes portes, puis... le système
rerejette les patients. Je veux
didire... C'est ce qu'on a vécu.
JeJe ne veux pas généraliser,
c'c'est ce qu'on a vécu,
mamalheureusement. Les signaux
ététaient très clairs, là.
MaMa fille en parlait ouverteme.
MaMa fille a fait des tentative.
IlIl n'y a rien qui peut être
bibien, bien plus clair que ça
popour prendre quelqu'un
enen charge, là.
- - Les signaux étaient clairs,e
ppère a le courage d'interpeller
leles autorités.
LeLe coroner a déclaré qu'il y
auaurait une enquête publique du
cocoroner sur la mort d'Amélie
chchampagne. On s'est tourné ves
leles autorités.
MoMon invité, Lionel Carmant,
miministre sortant délégué à la
SaSanté et aux Services sociaux.
BoBonsoir, monsieur Carmant.
- - Bonsoir.
- - C'est inacceptable et
inindécent, c'est un scandale.
- - Je voudrais commencer par
sosouhaiter mes condoléances à a
fafamille. Ce qui s'est passé et
susurtout ce sentiment d'être
rerejeté que M. Champagne décri,
c'c'est inacceptable et c'est pr
cecela que d'hier soir on a
dedemandé de lancer une enquête
pupublique.
- - Vous ressentez cela? Vous
rereconnaissez ce que le père dt
: : quelle a été rejetée par le
sysystème?
- - Le fait qu'il a eu ce
sesentiment, c'est inacceptablet
ilil faut aller au fond des
chchoses.
- - Allô récapitulons. Elle est
alallée à l'hôpital Douglas, one
sasait pas ce qui s'est passé l-
babas, en cas de CoronaVac de le
rérévéler. Mais arrivé dans une
ururgence après une tentative de
susuicide, se retrouver deux nus
etet trois jours dans le chaos
tototal avec des gens en psycho,
elelle voulait sortir de là. Vos
etet moi, on ne pourrait pas le
susupporter et elle, elle est
mamalade.
- - Et sa principale plainte étt
unun manque de sommeil. Alors il
fafaut que je comprenne ce qui a
momotivé sa décision. Et pourqui
onon est arrivé là.
- - Mais comment se fait-il que
nonos urgences psychiatriques
sosoient dans cet état? Parce qe
sasa détresse, ce n'est pas du
sasang que l l'on voit. Si elle
avavait saigné on l'aurait toute
susuite soigné mais sa détresse
esest invisible. Et ma question,
cocomment se fait-il que nos
ururgences psychiatriques sont
dadans cet état là?
- - Il y a deux choses.
PrPremièrement, vu le triage à
l'l'urgence, le problème
pspsychiatrique est souvent géré
enen P4 ou P5, donc des délais
trtrès longs avant d'être évalu.
LaLa deuxième problématique, c't
quque les durées de séjour des
papatients en psychiatrie sont
exextrêmement longs. Alors nous,
onon propose deux solutions dans
nonotre plan d'action, c'est
prpremièrement de mettre guicheà
l'l'urgence avec infirmière,
trtravailleuse sociale et des
inintervenants communautaires pr
nonon seulement évaluaient la
sisituation mais s'assurer une
cocontinuité dans la communauté.
DeDeuxièmement, je pense que c't
imimportant, on a fait une annoe
auaussi d'hospitalisation à
dodomicile. Il faut diminuer les
hohospitalisations en psychiatre
ququi dure extrêmement longtemp.
- - Elle était très bien entoure
papar sa famille et le père s'et
mmême levé pour voir si elle
ététait dans son lit et quelques
miminutes plus tard elle s'était
jejetée du 16e étage. Ma questi,
çaça fait trop longtemps que les
ururgences en psychiatrie sont..
cece n'est pas le premier
rereportage que l'on a, c'est
paparce que les patients urgencs
atattendent d'abord un lit, il y
enen a pas assez.
PaParce qu'il y a des gens qui e
pepeuvent pas être à domicile.
- - La situation en psychiatrie
esest la même que dans le resteu
réréseau. Manque de personnel ac
leles enjeux de la COVID-19, doc
c'c'est la même situation.
- - Alors elle avait le mauvais
cocode postal. Vouous rejetez ce
prpratique ou pas?
- - Je ne la comprends pas. Si a
papatiente est prise en charge à
l'l'hôpital aux urgences, il fat
quque la situation soit bien
écéclaircie pour expliquer
popourquoi on l'a congédié. Tout
sisimplement parce qu'on veut la
trtransférer à un autre hôpital?
SuSurtout quand l'hôpital n'a ps
dede lit disponible, si j'ai bin
cocompris la situation.
IlIl aurait pu y avoir un
trtransfert d'hôpital l'hôpital
mamais ce qui s'est passé, c'est
cece qu'on a besoin de comprend.
- - Mais vous savez que très
sosouvent et je vais vous situer
unun autre cas tout à l'heure,
cecelui dans Lanaudière, le jeue
SaSamuel Santos, dont la mère a
tétémoigné il n'y a pas longtem,
c'c'était arrivé au début de
l'l'année. C'est une pratique qi
sese fait dans les hôpitaux pour
didire : on a assez de monde ic,
alallez vous faire soigner
aiailleurs. Vous le savez qu'on
apapplique cette idée qu'on a le
mamauvais code postal. Pouvez-vs
chchanger cette pratique?
- - Je pense que les patients ot
lele droit de recevoir des soins
llà où il se présente et c'est
dadans la L4S.
OnOn doit s'en assurer.
- - Que pouvez-vous vous déroget
cece soir qui ont besoin de sois
mamais qui ne les ont pas à caue
dede mauvais code postal?
- - Que l'on ne veut plus voir
cecette situation et on va
reregarder ce qui se passe danse
réréseau
- - Et si cela arrive de façon
rérépétée. Mais ça arrive souve,
leles gens se sur le fond de
sosouvent plus surtout en santé
mementale. Vous le savez.
- - Peut-être pour une prise en
chcharge en externe. C'est sûr e
cece que l'on veut, c'est une
prprise en charge de la communaé
mamais là, on parle d'un cas
ururgent en détresse. Je ne cros
papas que ça doit survenir.
- - Êtes-vous entre de me dire e
lala famille qui ne pouvait pas
prprotester contre des pratiques
adadministratives comme celle-là
auaurait pu dire : non, vous alz
l'l'hospitaliser ici et on va
avavoir un lit.
C'C'est que le climat dans
l'l'urgence était tellement
ininhospitalier que cela la
rerendait encore plus malade.
- - C'est pour ça qu'il faut alr
vovoir au fond des choses et c't
popour cela qu'on l'demandait
l'l'enquête du coroner pour voir
ququelles pratiques à cause de
ceceux-ci. Ou est-ce que le
sysystème a failli? Et qu'est-ce
ilil faut changer? Et on va le
chchanger.
- - Et le père a dit, je compte
c'c'étais aux médecins résident,
popour qui sans doute la pressin
esest très forte : si vous la
lalaissez aller, vous allez avor
unune mort sur la conscience. La
fafamille ne voulait pas qu'on a
lalaisse aller. Il voulait qu'on
lului trouve un lit.
- - Je comprends bien et il y a
dedes enjeux de diagnostic
pspsychiatrique parce
ququ'effectivement...
- - Mais le débordement, le mane
dede lits. Pourquoi les unités
pspsychiatriques n'a pas plus de
lilit?
- - Parce que les durées de séjr
enen psychiatrie sont extrêmemet
lolongues. Donc il faut s'assurr
jujustement et c'est pour cela e
l'l'on propose hospitalisation à
dodomicile pour qu'on limite le
nonombre d'hospitalisations en
pspsychiatrie. C'est pour cela
auaussi qu'on veut éviter que ls
gegens attendent trop à l'urgene
enen ayant des guichet spécialié
etet un suivi dans la communauté
susuite à la visite à l'urgence.
C'C'est ça qui a manqué ici
bebeaucoup.
- - Alors là le coroner va pouvr
enenquête cela est convoqué qui
elelle veut parce que l'enquêtea
êêtre publique?
- - Exactement. La jeune adulte
auaurait pu être référée vers un
cecentre de crise. Il y avait
d'd'autres solutions disponibles
etet ce suivi dans la communauté
auaurait dû être fait.
- - Mes partie à ce moment-là?
- - Par les équipes de l'urgenc.
- - Mais si ces équipes sont
dédébordées, tandis que l'argent
quque vous avez promis parce que
leles listes d'attente en santé
mementale, on est passé de 16 00
àà 21 000. Les gens n'ont pas
acaccès à des soins.
- - C'est sûr qu'avec la pandéme
ilil y a eu une explosion de pls
dede 40 % des demandes. Les liss
d'd'attente relativement stable.
LeLes chiffres de 16 000 étages
quque l'on a eus en septembre 20
etet je pense que c'était peut-
êêtre un peu biaisé par les
efeffets de la pandémie et le pu
dede consultation parce que Mon-
dede-Marsan n'était à 19 000.
JeJe pense qu'il faut dire que s
inintervenants font un travail
exexceptionnel.
- - Absolument et sans doute les
mémédecins en cause sont en sous
prpression aussi parce que si iy
a a un cas d'urgence
pspsychiatrique, tout ce que l'n
a a à offrir est une civière das
unun corridor. Je vous entendre
llà-dessus.
- - Il faut faire mieux, je suis
d'd'accord mais on a augmenté ls
bubudgets de façon significativ.
- - Mais pas encore.
- - Mais on va continuer
d'd'investir en santé mentale.
DaDans les dernières années on a
auaugmenté de 700 intervenants
dadans le réseau de la santé
mementale et on va continuer
d'd'ajouter du monde. On a proms
d'd'ajouter 1000 intervenants au
cocourant des prochaines années.
OnOn veut travailler  à bâtir. e
pepense qu'on est le gouvernemet
ququi s'intéresse plus à la sané
mementale depuis des années. J'i
prpratiqué 24 à Saint Justine, l
y y avait des problèmes d'accès
auaux soins depuis toujours.
- - L'autre cas dont je vous
paparlais, qui est en est presqe
cocopié coller à celui d'Amélie
chchampagne qui est t absolument
drdramatique, présenté la semaie
dedernière dans les journaux. Vs
avavez dû le voir dans votre ree
dede presse. Une mère qui
tétémoigne. Le jeune homme a 16
anans, Samuel Santos, il doit
alaller plusieurs événements
l'l'amène à l'urgence
pspsychiatrique de l'hôpital Le
GaGardeur. Or, il est censé y
avavoir 10 pédopsychiatres, il y
enen a huit qui ont démissionné
dedepuis des mois, c'est une
sisituation qui s'aggrave de mos
enen mois. Et le jeune état
d'd'urgence psychiatrique adult,
fifinalement la mère aussi voult
ququ'il aille à Saint Justine oà
MoMontréal et elle aussi avait e
mamauvais code postal.
ElElle a déclaré aux journaux :
mamauvais code postal. Le jeune
hohomme finalement meurt d'une
susurdose parce qu'il y avait de
lala drogue mêlée à son état. Il
memeurt à l'hôpital le 1er janvr
dedernier d'une surdose parce
ququ'il a été traité trop tard.
EsEst-ce que l'enquête du coronr
popourrait examiné ce cas aussi?
- - C'est quelque chose qui est
sosoulevé, je pense que le coror
a a toute la latitude possible.
MaMais ce que vous touchez le
prproblème de demande psychiatre
etet surtout de pédopsychiatres.
- - Pour 106 000 enfants il y a
dedeux psychiatres et 800 parti.
PoPourquoi sont-ils partis?
- - Certains vont priver et
d'd'autres vont faire autre cho.
IlIls prennent leur retraite. On
trtravaille avec l'association s
mémédecins psychiatres sur cet
exexode vers le privé des médecs
pspsychiatres. Il s'en a demandé
popour les régions en pénurie de
psychiatres, qu'il y ait un
reregroupement qui se fasse, que
leles résolutions biseautées coe
MoMontréal, Québec, qu'elle viee
enen aide avec les régions où iy
a a une pénurie. Et pendant la
papandémie, une des bonnes choss
etet qu'il y a eu la consultatin
tétélévisuelle en santé mentale,
enen psychiatrie. Il faut que ca
cocontinu. C'est un outil qui et
ututile que les psychiatres nous
onont dit.
- - Mais ce soir, dans le cas de
MaMadame champagne, ses clients,
sosolidarité, les parents ont
enenterré leur fait en fin de
sesemaine. Le cas de Samuel
SaSantos, je leur étais et je vs
lele soumets sont deux cas où le
cocode postal a été évoqué poure
papas prendre en charge.
PoPourquoi? Parce que les hôpitx
dédébordent, les autres urgences
dédébordent. Et en plus vous êts
reresponsables de la protectione
lala jeunesse. Un enfant en
ururgence psychiatrique du côté
adadulte, ça n'a aucun bon sens.
CeCertains diraient que c'est
mimieux cela que rien mais quand
mmême.
- - Et aussi dans Lanaudière
auaussi, en pédopsychiatrie, jee
sasais pas ce qui s'est passé ds
cece dossier mais je pense que i
c'c'est vraiment un enjeu de coe
popostal et que le coroner nous
didit que c'est vraiment pour ca
ququ'elle n'a pu être transféré,
onon va changer les choses en
tetemps et lieu.
- - Docteur clairement, merci
bebeaucoup. Je sais que vous êts
enen campagne électorale. Ça c't
ininvité, personne ne veut en
fafaire une question de
papartisanerie politique. C'est
trtrop grave. Peut-être que la
sasanté mentale et l'angle morte
lala santé tout court?
- - C'était important pour moi
d'd'être là pour la santé mentae
a a longtemps été sous financée.
OnOn a amorcé un rattrapage
imimportant dans les quatre
dederniers années et on va
cocontinuer.
- - Merci beaucoup d'avoir acceé
dede nous parler. On va évidemmt
enencore une fois, on peut voirn
nunuméro à l'écran pour les
pepersonnes en détresse.
1-1-866-APPELLE
1-1-866-277-3553
OfOffrir encore une fois nos
cocondoléances à la famille
chchampagne. Également à toute